you know only in school systems the
things that continue to fail we put more
and more money and sure we should try to
fix them but at some point all you're
doing is throwing good money after bad
and worse than the money is the kids I'm
Catherine mengjie award for recent TV
joining me today is Joel Klein the
former Chancellor of the New York City
Schools and the author of a new book
lessons of Hope how to fix the schools
could you start just telling us a little
bit about why you wrote the book and
what's in it sure Katherine I really
wanted people who are not part of the
education system to get a feel for what
it's like in sorry the largest most
complex bureaucracy in America the New
York City Public Schools is 135,000
employs 1.1 million children second
reason I write the book is I am
convinced that if we don't dramatically
change our education system we as a
country are going to pay an enormous
price for it so Bill DeBlasio is
launching a new 150 million dollar
program to do wraparound services and
try and improve failing schools what do
you think about that wraparound services
are always a good idea but if in the end
they don't hold schools accountable for
performance they're gonna pay a big
price for that I think the thing you're
most famous for is closing failing
schools can you talk about sort of why
you want that route as opposed to
dumping more money into failing schools
or somehow trying to rejigger them why
shut the doors when you get a culture of
failure that continues to repeat itself
at some point you need new beginnings
and we insisted on that it made
accountability real the people in the
school knew that if they kept doing the
same things that they weren't going to
be able to continue to survive as a
school and we felt that sending kids to
perpetual failure factories hoping and
wishing for change it's not a winning
strategy you know only in school systems
the things that continue to fail we put
more and more money and so we should try
to fix them but at some point all you're
doing is throwing good money after bad
and worse than the money is the kids who
you know are consigned to a future into
a school that won't work for them where
people spending went up quite a lot
during your tenure
was the money worth it yeah because it
brought better teachers to the system
and is that where the money went for
teacher salaries by and large I mean no
one tells the things well but 43% raised
and teacher salaries directed a lot of
money some of them went for capital
improvement some of them went to lower
class size in the earlier years but most
of it went not just teachers our
principal assistant principal and so
forth and again I would rather spend the
money more rationally but attracting
more committed teachers higher
performing teachers higher prepared
teachers really matters you got some
pushback on spending some of that money
on outside consultants to sort of work
with the schools and the principals I do
you think those consultants were we're
worth their weight in gold in the end or
not every concern is worth is our weight
in gold but most of the money we use for
outside consultants came from private
monies we raise from charitable
foundations we raised hundreds of
millions of dollars because people saw
what was going on in New York that's a
real transformational City we had the
mayor there for 12 years I was there for
eight and a half years some work we did
with consultants we tried and didn't
work particularly well but that's
inevitable but one of the things that
troubles me is that if you don't try new
and different things then his school
system won't change and if you do try
knowing different things not everything
you do will work not everything in
Silicon Valley turns out to be Facebook
or Google and we've got to try and we've
got to be willing to innovate and that
risks not succeeding and everything you
do and that happened to us let's cut to
the chase this is a national problem we
just heard from Jeb Bush the opening
keynote address here would you vote for
president Jeb Bush never get into
politics my I've worked for President
Clinton I'm a Democrat and I just hope
whoever it's like the president does the
right thing for schools because it's so
critical to our nation it's a very
diplomatic answer I last years of
chancellors have you learn a little
diplomacy I'll try to ask you a more
diplomatic question then which is if a
hypothetical education reformer managed
to win the White House what would you
want to see him do first well I think
anybody in the White House ought of
really do two things one focus and
national attention to this issue America
is not performing globally where we need
to perform our kids are not performing
right now some 40 to 50 to 60% of our
kids are graduating from high school
wholly unprepared for what's ahead of
them it's not a winning game second
thing I would like to see is the federal
government use its efforts use its money
to stimulate much greater choice so that
our kids get the opportunities across
the board that to me is a critical
policy that will bring both competition
energy and dynamism third thing focus on
innovation and in just yesterday
President Obama had a conference in the
White House trying to drive innovation
which I support wholeheartedly thank you
very much for taking time to talk with
us thank you
[Music]